[Music]  I'm actually working with lot of like  spas wellness centers yeah actually I  have some at at a clinic for kids with  autism and really yeah and kids with  chronic pain it helps him because  sensory integration you know for her kid  with autism he needs  she needs basically a little bit of  stimulation but it's nice when you would  want to get away especially kids like  that a lot of action is scary so it's a  nice little right yeah they kind of  thump get into just a really relaxed  state that's why he is definitely hot in  there poke up where did they take my  iPod in there taking the iPod into the  meditation park I get where you're going  with this stuff